最近ずっと静岡にいるんで
平和な日常を送れていたんですけど
明日からしばらく東京にいます
（机に突っ伏す）
テンション上げよ
これぐらいの板ならおいらでも割れるわ
いくぜ！
ｱｱｱ
ねマジ割れそうなんだけど実際。
本気なら割れるわ
いきます
ﾎﾞｫﾝ
（痛ｯ!!!!）
ｱｱｱ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです。
えー
受験生のみなさま
お受験お疲れ
あっまだやっている人もいるかもしれない
そんなテキトーなこと言えないんですけど
来年受験生の方はそろそろ本腰を入れるころかな
春から中3、高3になる人たち
そろそろ　もう
やっちゃっていいんじゃないですかね
というわけでそろそろ
春休みという方もいると思いますが
やっぱ新学期はこう心機一転して
文房具がほしくなるわけでございますよ
今回は・・・
すごいと思う
はいこちら！
はぁい！
オレンズ、、オレンズナノ
もうなんか箱がすごいよね
メカニカル感がすごい
計算されてんのかいろいろ
やべ　久々すぎて
みんな忘れてるかもしんないけど
おぉれ　文房具オタクなんだ
まぁ正確にいえばシャーペンなんですけど
シャーペンが好きすぎて
定期的にシャーペンの紹介してたんですけども
まぁ最近あんまりやってなかったんですけれども
これはちょっとすごいなと思って買ってみました
値段だよぉ
値段、値段、値段、、
オレンズネロのまず値段がすごかった気がする
なんでネロっていうんだろうねぇ
うぅぅ
かっこいいなー
えーめっちゃかっこいいじゃんこれ
商品の特徴
最高峰なの、、？
まってこれやべ
なるほどなるほど、、
そうそうそう、、
えっと
そうだよねぇ
あーなるほどね
芯自動出し機能？
えやばいじゃん
あー　これはぁ
すごいなぁ、、
はーん
うっわー！
あ震える～
今いろいろ調べてたんですけども、
ぺんてるさんのなんか、、集大成感があるなぁこれは
ちょっと開けていきましょうか
あ、値段、値段、値段
あーなるほど
えと、これ
すげーなぁ～
3000円のシャーペンって
なかなかそうないと思いますよ
海外のラミーとか
じゃちょっと開けていきましょう
こわいよぉ、、
開けまっせ
おお、中身は結構すっきりしてるな
んん？？
取扱説明書か
キシリトールかと思ったわ
うぉお
オレンズネロの説明書ですね
もうしっかり書いてありますね
オレンズっていうのは
芯が折れないシャープペンシルでした
で、今回のこのオレンズネロって、
何かといいますと、
自動芯出し機構がついているらしいので
簡単に言えば
これ1本で
自動芯出し機構がついているので
1回芯を出せば
つまり！
シャー芯が折れなくて
1回ノックするだけで
永遠に描き続けられる
※芯がある限り
もう 最強のシャーペンらしいです。
ﾋｭ~（口笛）
ただね、オレンズはね、
芯がね、
芯の太さが
まぁその分そもそもとがらなくていいっていうね
クルトガが本来補うべきであった機能を
芯を細くすることによって無くしている
という利点はあります
だからまぁあんまり気にしなくても細いんでしょうね
そもそも
見た目こんな感じでございます
やはり製図用シャーペン寄りのこの
ちょっと出てる感じ
ペン先が見えて書きやすいはずです
おお
かっけーなー
やっぱり黒っていいよね
ああ、ネロって
これすごいなぁ
まぁ実際に書いてみないと分かんないんですけども、
ちょっとまとめさせてください
値段なりの、たぶん、あるんだと思います
オレンズだから
なんか学生が終わってからそんなに
シャーペン持つことないんですけども、
なにーかね、何かたまに
替えたりするんですよ
1回書いてみましょう
これだともうたぶん芯が出すぎですね
もうね、見えないくらいでいいんですよ
これくらいちょびっと出てるだけで多分
書き続けられるはず
じゃあ書いてみましょうか
待って
この感じに永遠書けるとことか
えっ、すごいよ、これ
というわけでちょっと書いてみたんですけども、
僕正直言いますと、
結構太めで書きたい人間なんですけれども
重心が低くてなんか個人的に
いや、これ3000円分の価値あります
はぁ、もうやばいわ　なんか東大行ける気がしてきた
というわけで、ちょっと書いてみたんですけども、
すごいですよ
もう手が震えちゃってるもん
だてに3000円だなっていう感じはしました。
あのSMASHとかホントに最高のシャーペンだったし、
オレンズも芯折れなくてすごいいいと思ったし、
そのいいところだけを取り寄せて作った
なんか集大成というか、
気合が入ってるなって感じた1品でした
まず黒っていうのがもうずるいよ、黒
やっぱシャーペンって結局ねぇ
赤もいいですよ、赤もいいです。
赤黒だとなおよし。赤黒だとなおよし。
なんですけども、
結局黒が1番かっこいいと思ってます
もと黒いシャーペンの男いたらどうするよぉ？
おんなのこのみんな
惚れるでしょ～？
せやろ～？
いやかっこいいなぁ、、
マジで惚れたわ
えっと、新学期始まると思います
そして春休みの宿題もあると思います
そして、来年いよいよ受験だよっという人
もうスタートしちゃっていいともいます。
新しく学校に入学した皆さん
スタートダッシュが肝心やで。
いや、本当にいいシャーペンでした
3000円の価値は僕は正直あると思います。
ｳﾞｧｱｲ!